on a créé de toutes pièces un événement
qui était contraire au droit
international pour justifier
l'intervention au nom de la
responsabilité de protéger qui est qui
et qui est défini par un par les nations
unies et ça a été le massacre de
benghazi que qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs
dans beaucoup de d'articles aujourd'hui
alors qu'on sait et qu'on savait à
l'époque qu'il n'avait jamais eu lieu on
a des rapports des services de rendement
car à la même époque qui précise qu'il
n'y a jamais eu ce massacre
mais il a servi de prétexte et il reste
aujourd'hui inscrits dans les dents dans
l'immédiat d'une manière générale
manière indélébile et il continue d'une
certaine manière à excuser
l'intervention occidentale
[Musique]